warning the video you're about to watch
or this will happen to you okay Colin
[Music]
doughnuts another adventure we're about
to do some donuts chef telephone we're
gonna try to find the best donuts in LA
we're gonna go to one donut shop then
we're gonna ask them what their favorite
doughnut is and we're gonna go to the
next donut shop the next donut shop
until we find the best donut in all of
Los Angeles donuts are my weakness I'm
on a lifestyle called paleo - Donuts
it's all about the Krispy Kreme was the
that'll be in Ohio
no freshness is obviously the most
important thing well see miss sugar - da
Vinci I compared donut shops based on
their chocolate frosted donut I said we
knew that this donut look perfect I only
got hard on the inside actually to use
some authentic chocolate here and I
watched her put the chocolate on the top
[Music]
yeah the sugar to do ratio is
appropriate it doesn't taste ready ain't
ready donut okay that's good you don't
know it in your hair donut friend me my
friend four out of five what is that
about gonna miss no but this is the
first donut place I'm not gonna start
out with five out of five and then just
assume there's no
but this one is called the Surya Rogers
son what happened put like a range of
emotions but is actually pleasant I mean
it's a meal you know like when you feed
too much information to computer it lets
us down rebuild every time we'd go to a
donut shop we asked the people at that
donut shop what their favorite donut
spot to eat at is when you're not here
donut man in Glendora Collins already
conked out he's in doughnut coma telling
that delirium thank you I heard about
this place for a long time my dad grew
up out here is it like it I don't know I
feel like this place is really really
like on par with making things look
really cool hey Jase Cheers
it's nice and light dense and fluffy
yeah it's that weird perfect combination
that you don't see in Donuts very often
it's pretty cool chocolate frosted donut
is more like the icy who consoled you
when you're down next up we got this
strawberry insanity situation here I
feel like I'm eating a bread bowl of
soup but instead of soup it's
strawberries yeah you know I just
realized what you can't have too many go
nuts
this isn't like tacos tacos like your D
tacos all day and you just get full this
like like feel like I might I'm doomed
out I do not what I eat anymore we're
gonna do it besides the doughnuts here
where would you suggest that we should
go to next for our next
um all my coworkers are saying ladies
donuts and ladies donuts is right down
the street
ladies donuts unfortunately didn't want
to be on camera so we're asking the
internet widow said California donut
California donuts here we come
[Music]
I was a doughnut I would be like
something like apple cinnamon I see that
little bit of sweet a little bit of
spicy I'm a Chuck covered old-fashioned
white chocolate covered because I like
chocolate I think I'd be maple bacon
many layers to the dividend many layers
to my life I don't want to say basic
boring all glazed doughnut but I think
I'd be a basic floor and lays doughnut
I'd really like the kind of bread that
you've got an Asian bakery you can tell
it's quality dough more ready than I
would prefer very good I would like to
combine the dome from California
doughnut with the chocolate glazed
doughnut make my figures donut man in
Glendora I think that was a special this
is my favorite donut donut shop
telephone works I'm gonna have to say
that donut friend had my favorite
chocolate plane I would say this donut
wins on sugar to the ratio let's get
crazy
I'm gonna give this burning to you on
right there you like that no what's it
taste like it tastes like this is my
favorite done it a long time now I have
had a maple bacon cronut before but not
from here
that's a ranger it's the bacon I think
it's because I'm finally getting some
savory in my mouth I've never picked out
of anything else to this degree that
made me feel as awful as I do right now
that's are no joke I've been training
for this like my whole life I still eat
at least six Donuts every weekend yeah
another lyrium is not an ideal state to
be in but if you're with people that you
love it's all worth it crazy weird yeah
you like you're crazy donors like you'd
like a crazy man